vamos a ver otro ejemplo de división
sintética después vamos a ver por qué
funciona pero ahorita simplemente vamos
a seguir el proceso para que te
acostumbres a los pasos es más si
quieres puedes intentar el problema por
ti mismo bueno qué es lo primero que
tenemos que hacer en división sintética
lo primero es escribir los coeficientes
tenemos que escribir los coeficientes
aquí abajo déjame hacer eso este 2 lo
voy a poner por aquí 2 luego tendría que
poner el menos 1 pero ojo aquí el 12 es
el expone el coeficiente de x a la
quinta y no tenemos término x a la
cuarta entonces tenemos que dejar de
cierta forma un espacio para considerar
ese x a la cuarta y lo que hacemos es
poner un cero va entonces este 12 es el
coeficiente de quizá la quinta y este 0
es el coeficiente de quizá la cuarta
porque no hay coeficientes de quizá la
cuarta bueno teniendo cuidado con eso
seguimos luego hay que poner el de x
ubica que sería este menos uno menos uno
está multiplicando x cúbica luego
tendríamos que poner este 3
3 positivo luego este menos 2 - 2 y
finalmente el 7 el 7 ok entonces ahí
están los numeritos déjame poner el
símbolo chistoso y divertido que indica
que vamos a hacer una división sintética
que es éste de acá
y ojo ojo estamos usando división
sintética porque en el denominador
tenemos x a la potencia 1 nada más y su
coeficiente es 1 entonces realmente este
método sólo aplica para cuando tenemos
cosas del estilo x más menos algo en
este caso tenemos x menos 3 bueno ahora
este menos 3 tenemos que pasarlo para
acá pero con signo contrario entonces si
aquí dice menos 3 acá tenemos que
pasarlo como 3 entonces lo voy a poner
aquí como
muy bien entonces vamos a hacer la
división sintética entonces los pasos
dicen que hagamos lo siguiente que este
2 lo bajemos directamente este 2 lo
bajamos directamente para acá luego
hacemos dos por tres es 6 entonces aquí
hacia arriba ponemos el 6 para luego
tenemos que sumar 0.6 0.66 bueno ahora
hay que hacer 3 por 6 3 por 6 de 18 y
ese 18 lo tenemos que poner aquí déjame
agarrar el color amarillo para poner
aquí el 18 muy bien ahora 18 menos 118 -
1 es 17 lo ponemos aquí abajo
17 ahora tenemos que multiplicar 17 por
3 sin los números ya se están volviendo
algo grandes pero bueno le seguimos 17
por 3 3 por 7 es 21 y llevamos 2 y 3 por
1 3 y 2 que llevamos son 51 muy bien 51
a este 51 le tenemos que sumar el 3 nos
daría 54 y ahora 3 por 54 3 por 54 3 por
50 es 153 por 4 es 12 entonces de 150
más 12 o sea 162 162 y ahora tenemos que
restar 2 162 menos 260 y la última
multiplicación es 3 x 160 que son 480
no voy a poner en color amarillo 480 y
esta última suma nos da 487 400 lo voy a
poner con el color azul que le tocan 487
muy bien entonces aquí ya tenemos los
coeficientes de la respuesta parece
magia en cierto sentido sí lo es porque
no lo hemos demostrado después vamos a
ver cómo se muestra pero bueno entonces
lo que obtenemos es que esta expresión
es igual a es igual a y déjame empezar
por la derecha empezamos con este 487
que es el residuo entonces tenemos que
ponerlo aquí como 487 487 entre entre x
menos 3 x menos 3
y luego vamos hacia la izquierda
entonces este 160 es el término
constante ese término constante lo
ponemos aquí 160 luego va el de el de
grado 1 que es el 54
entonces le ponemos más 54 x 54 lo voy a
poner un poco más grande 54 x luego va a
este 17 que es el de grado 2 entonces
sería más 17 x al cuadrado 17 x al
cuadrado para este que es el del cúbico
verdad del de grado 3 lo pongo en color
blanco más 6 x al cubo y finalmente va
este 2 y este 2 nos dice que aquí va un
2 x a la cuarta lo pongo por ahí 2 x a
la cuarta muy bien entonces nos da este
resultado de aquí entonces tenemos que
cuando hacemos la división nos queda
esta expresión
te recomiendo verificar que de adeveras
nos da esto ya sea multiplicando por x
menos 3 o bien haciendo la tradicional
división